hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial and in this video i'll be
showing you how to download and install
the firefox 3.1 beta 2. um i already
showed you guys how to install the fire
to the safari 4 beta so here we go with
firefox 3.1 beta 2. so just open up
firefox and go to any popular search
engine i'll use google for this one and
type in firefox 3.1 beta
and the first link which i'll try to put
in the description for you guys
is going to be the firefox or the
mizzle.com website
and it's going to tell us obviously
firefox is firefox 3.1 is not completely
fully out yet
but um it's going to have a ton of new
features obviously and it's available in
as you can see here over 50 languages
so
uh we can see by the top it's available
number one in a ton of languages and
number two as we see across here
available for mac os 10 for windows xp
vista and later versions in earlier
versions and for linux so i'm going to
hit the download button for windows
all right and it's going to pop up right
here in a second saying to save this
file or to download it i'm just going to
download it actually i'm going to save
the file to my desktop
and the first thing i want to tell you
guys about is that not all of your
add-ons are going to be compatible if
you do have add-ons that you're using in
your current version of
firefox which i'll check just by going
to help and about firefox this is
version
3.0.6 so i'll hit ok
um so it's downloading the file not all
of your add-ons are going to be
compatible so i'll let you guys know
which one of my add-ons actually aren't
compatible with firefox in a later
review i'm going to do a later review of
safari 4 beta and a later review of this
beta so i'm going to double click on it
when it's done downloading and hit run
and it's going to begin extracting so
i'm just going to exit out of
firefox itself to give this most room in
ram for actually extracting and
finishing the installation so here we go
once it's finished extracting it'll
bring up the installer and if uac does
pop up just hit continue you're going to
have to continue and allow everything
for the installation for the
installation to work completely and just
for this tutorial i'm going to unload
firefox preloader because i have a
feeling it's not going to work if i
don't so
quit firefox completely
so welcome to the safari 3.1 beta 2
setup just hit continue
and i'm going to do a custom setup here
because i don't want to use this firefox
as my default web browser quite yet
and this is exactly where i do want to
install it now it's going to replace
your current version of firefox and you
can see right here it has a 24 um it'll
take up roughly 25 megabytes in your on
your hard drive so i am going to put a
icon on my desktop because i actually
want to drag it up here to my rocket
dock
and number two i do want to put it in my
start programs folder and i don't want
it in my quick launch bar so i hit next
and next again and it will begin
installing there we go
so i'll just come back to you guys when
this is done with the installation
process
okay as you can see here it is completed
with the setup and i'm going to
leave the launch firefox now button
ticked and just hit finish and this will
finish the installation of firefox and
open it up and you can also see up here
they've nicely put that icon on my
desktop so i can show you guys later how
to put it in the rocket dock so right
now i'm just going to let it open itself
up it's going to take a while for the
first boot for obviously a new piece of
software or hardware first of checking
my add-on incompatibility it says the
following add-ons are not compatible
look at all those add-ons that i have
that are not compatible so i told you
guys that these are not compatible i'll
check now
and it was it was not able to find any
add-on updates so i'll just hit finish
and i won't be able to use any of those
add-ons in the new beta version of
firefox so that's pretty interesting
so i'll let uh firefox finish uploading
or finish opening and obviously it's
going to open in more than one tab so it
still has this new tab button which is
an add-on i got
and so firefox 3.1 is coming so this is
the feedback button if you do find a bug
you can file a bug or hit the feedback
button and tell them i'm just going to
hit exit because i know the
incompatibility is going to happen in a
beta
so
next we're going to do
um basically we already know that the
beta
is incompatible with a lot i just go to
tools and add-ons and we see here
there's a lot there's two of my themes
are not compatible okay if you want to
use mac os 10 theme it is not compatible
so i'll just hit uninstall since it's
not going to work and this graphite
theme is uninstalled because it's not
going to work
and that's basically it so i like this
theme i'm using it right now so i'll hit
exit
and i've heard a lot of good things
about it so i'll type in i still have my
google toolbar here i'll go to the acid
three test and just check this out the
first link is acid three
and we told you already that the safari
4 beta got a 100 out of 100 and firefox
3.1 beta stops just short at 93.
uh youtube loads pretty fast it still
remembers my username and password yes
it does
it's pretty good
um it still is going to have the same
right click options um i still have the
download download them all add-on you
know not much different i still have the
uh
the loading progress bar up here so
that's an add-on that still works but
that's basically it so if i wanted to um
use the tutorial that i did for you guys
on how to use a background
if i actually found a video i wanted to
use as a background
say maybe this one i can still go to
that image
right click it and hit um where is it
here
i can still hit oh set his desktop
background
right here and it'll bring up the same
window so that's pretty cool
so yeah i've heard a lot of good things
about the speed of firefox 3.1 beta 2
and i'm going to show you now how to add
it to your rocket dock right now i'm
going to unlock items
just drag out the old firefox icon it'll
disappear
take the firefox 3.1 beta icon and drag
it in and that's all you have to do i'm
just going to lock it up again and we're
done
to put it in your quick launch same
thing right click delete
delete the shortcut and then take the
new one and drag it in and now that
we're done using this shortcut i'm just
going to delete it from my desktop and
that is it
so i hope this tutorial was helpful and
if you found it helpful go ahead and
subscribe and if you have any tutorial
ideas for me send me a message subscribe
and i'll get back to in a request video
so thanks for watching guys peace